ladies and gentlemen Wendell quarry is  that most dangerous companion in the  theater an actor who can romp off with a  whole scene while you're clearing your  throat the kind of an actor who makes  other actors sit around in groups and  say I don't know that he's so good did  you notice that the only ones who seem  to like him were the people in the  audience  Wendell quarry will present the award  for the best achievement in film editing  mr. Wendell quarry Thank You Pam the  nominees for this award are Joan of Arc  Sierra Pictures RKO radio Frank Sullivan  Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers David  Weiss bod The Naked City Mark Hellinger  productions universal international Paul  Weatherwax Red River Monterey  productions United Artists Christian  naívi The Red Shoes J Arthur rank  archers eagle line British Reginald  Mills the winner Paul Weatherwax of The  Naked City Marc talented production of  universal international  Thank You mr. Cory